for the new king it's hardly a tough
crowd these people chose to queue
through a chilly night to pay their
respects to his mother
but his schedule is definitely grueling
he's toured the four countries of his
kingdom and last night stood vigil for
his mother before today visiting the
police and emergency services to be
briefed on plans for the queen's funeral
on monday
it was on his way back to the palace
that the king accompanied by the prince
of wales made an unannounced stop at the
queue
when they joined the line at half past
one this morning could any of these
exhausted cures have imagined they get a
chance to meet their equally exhausted
kid
the king spent more than 20 minutes
greeting mourners few of whom could
believe their long and winding path to
see the late monarch would lead them to
the new one as well i kissed his hand i
asked him if i could kiss his hand and
he said certainly the king then returned
to more formal matters greeting the
governors general of the 15 realms these
are the firsts of many handshakes over
the weekend more leaders from around the
world will arrive to pay their final
respects at the lake queens funeral
tom clark sky news